there's one thing one thing
that if you did every single day no joke
it would make
an extraordinary difference in whatever
mental health issue you're struggling
with
what most people know is emotion is
created by motion the way you move
determines the way you feel go
read something that will help you feel
better that will help you
find your way again wanna be happy
live a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the five habits
that will crush
your depression
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one exercise with mel robbins
if you have depression if you have
anxiety if you have post-traumatic
stress disorder if you have
any kind of mental health condition it's
nothing to be ashamed of and it's
nothing to hide
and it's something to hit head-on with
there's one thing
one thing that if you did every single
day no joke
it would make an extraordinary
difference in whatever mental health
issue you're struggling with
and that is exercise and the reason why
i say this is not based on my own
personal experience
it's based on the fact that the um
i think it's the american psychiatric
association this is coming from dr john
ratey a friend of mine who has written a
ton of books
about not only adhd but also the
benefits of exercise and what it has on
your brain
but he's also a professor at harvard and
a practicing
clinician and this is his area of
expertise
and one of the things that they now
mandate as a diagnosis for anybody with
depression or anxiety
or any mental illness frankly is you've
got to exercise every day
and the reason you've got to exercise
every day is because what we know about
human beings is that when you physically
move
your physiology changes and that changes
your brain
getting your heart rate up getting
outside breathing
feeling connected getting out of your
house which may make you feel depressed
and trapped
doing that every day that physical push
you don't have to run
you don't have to go to an aerobics
class get outside with your dog in the
woods
walk with a good friend for two or three
miles doing that every single day
not only moves your body which changes
your mind it gets you out of your
physical environment which is one of the
things that people with depression tend
to have a hard time doing
and it also creates a bit of momentum
and a bit of a routine in your life
you take on just that single thing
get outside and exercise every single
day as if your life depends upon it
because you know what
it does your brain needs it your body
needs it
your mental health needs it how about
number two prime your brain with tony
robbins
what most people know is emotion is
created by motion the way you move
determines the way you feel
you have 80 different muscles in your
face 80. for most people this is the
largest area of unemployment in the
country
they use their face the same way they
feel the same emotions over and over and
over again
so what i was saying is i have this deal
with myself called priming
every day i say look you've got to have
10 minutes for yourself you don't have
10 minutes for yourself you don't have a
life
and i'm not going to hope i feel good i
don't i just got back six countries in
12 days i was in india two days ago wow
i woke up here morning like feeling like
somebody ran me over with a truck
but you got yourself psyched but the way
i did is i do this process it's 10
minutes i put some music on i do this
massive change in my breathing so it
radically changes the way i feel
and then i do this three-step process
first i do three minutes of gratitude
where i think of three things i'm really
grateful for
and i associate i don't think of it over
there i feel it and the reason is
when you're grateful you can't be
worried you can't be fearful
when you're grateful you can't be angry
and anger and fear are what screw people
up most in their relationships and their
life and their business
so i wire myself i was saying to you
that most people want to be happy but
their habit is to be
worried or pissed off or frustrated or
stressed and so they're
they've got a highway to stress and they
got a dirt road to happiness
so i wire myself i've got a highway to
gratitude which changes all your
emotions and then i do
three minute process of kind of a prayer
for my family and friends and then i do
a three-minute process of the top three
things i want to accomplish i see it as
done and i feel
i'm done in 10 minutes so sometimes i go
20. but my deal is 10 so there's no
excuse not to do it
habit number three read with brendan
burchard
read a good book go pick up a great
personal development
book go pick up your bible or your quran
or whatever
spiritual text that you love go read
something
that will help you feel better that will
help you find your way again
i remember in college after i suffered a
very severe
bout of depression and suicidal thoughts
i started reading great books and it
started making me feel better you know i
read some of the greats and the classics
you know i read like paulo cuello's the
alchemist apollo is one of my great
friends and mentors and i've helped him
with his books and
he's been such a great influence in my
life now i i've been
i read books like uh i think it was
benjamin hoff who wrote
the tao of pooh as in winnie the pooh
that taught me about taoism they read
the tao of ching and that helped me feel
a little bit
better and then i started reading wayne
dyer you know and stephen covey
and i started reading dale carnegie and
listening earl nightingale
and i i'd read augmentino and some of
the classics from personal development
that
helped me started feeling better and
they didn't give me all the answers and
everything but they started sparking
ideas about living a better quality of
life
they gave me that that will that
motivation that hunger for something
again
and some times ambition sometimes
wanting something better
that's good to help us find our way to
start taking you know some more action
in our life all right my friend evan
carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
how about number four eat healthy with
marissa pier when someone is depressed
the best thing you can do is take them
delicious food
something really healthy and nourishing
like soup or chicken soup or
casseroles or vegetables don't
take chocolates or pizza because
depressed people find it very hard to
cook in my
experience depressed people have an
interesting line of thinking here's the
first thing they thought
there's no cure for depression which
actually isn't true and the second
thought is even if there was
it wouldn't work for me the third
thought is
i don't deserve it i find almost all the
people i work with feel
they don't deserve help and they're not
worthy
and most depressed people don't cook
they eat crackers potato chips a bit of
cheese some
coffee they don't shop for food they
don't cook
nutritious food because of this feeling
which is i'm
not worthy i'm not worth it so
an asset to someone who is depressed is
to take them
really healthy if you take them juices
take them fruit take them through
already chopped up and peeled in little
boxes
take them casseroles take them soups
they can at least
nourish their body inhabit number five
the last one before a very special bonus
clip
is spend time on yourself with edm
lent so many of us our identity is
caught up in our career
or who our children are right or who our
family is or our previous
story is our identity and we never
really get comfortable with who
we are which is the most powerful people
i know are the most self-aware
yeah they work on self-love the most
doesn't mean they like each themselves
all the time
right but i think you're kind of an
expert on this topic so talk a little
bit about
getting comfortable with you your own
skin who you are
right i think one of the best things
that you can do is getting to know
yourself
stripped of all the identities the world
gives you
you know yeah who are you without the
title yes
you know who are you without the
significance that the world gives you
and i have to figure that out because
of course like you said when i was a
football player and even now at rehab
time
you know the world will give me these
titles of who i am this is your identity
you have to be this person
and when you lose that you will lose
yourself god leave this
and so i literally i call it protecting
my peace i did it earlier out here i
mean a beautiful place to protect you
i do it every single day i protect my
peace by
diving in to who i am right my struggles
my insecurities things i'm tempted by i
get to know myself better and i think a
lot of people
they don't get to know themselves i
don't know they don't spend time i mean
i tweeted this out
uh not to i snapchat this out today and
someone says i can't be by myself
yes yep and i think one of the greatest
successes to be able to be by yourself
is still not for the long
oh my gosh i love that i love that
enjoy your own company man uh you know
what people a lot of people that follow
me are introverts like you and i and i
try to tell myself you know
one of the cool things about being an
introvert there's always good in what we
all have
one of the cool things about being an
introvert is for the most part
we are a little bit comfortable with
being by ourselves yes
we're almost uncomfortable with the
reverse right exactly and so but it is
important that people take this lesson
from you because i do likewise and that
is just spending some time alone
and getting to know yourself better with
your own thoughts whether it be
meditation prayer or just
talking to yourself that's right one of
the things that's a secret i'll tell
everybody about me is i talk to myself a
lot
i do it too do you really do it all the
time i talk to myself i tell people hey
you can if you're driving next to me in
the car you might see me talking to
myself that guy's
so glad to hear that no one's ever said
that back to me before
i don't feel so crazy since i was a
little boy probably because i was shy
and introverted there's all this chaos
in my life
i started talking to myself and it's in
it by the way it serves me to this day
i take a walk on the beach if you were
walking behind me you'd think i was
delusional
because it's not always quiet i'm so
glad to hear that back from you so
that's another key
like there's just you're loaded with all
these keys of how you transformed
yourself
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take
action on something you have a 91 chance
of following through
versus just 35 if you got motivated but
never wrote down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances
of following through even higher so
that's what i want to do
today for you guys you watch this video
what was your single biggest takeaway
and what is your plan to take action on
it
this week let me know put it down in the
comments below what do you say when you
see yourself in the mirror
when it's just you when you're all alone
it's just you you see yourself in the
mirror
what do you say do you say great things
or do you beat yourself up
most people they might act confident and
seem like they have it all put together
but secretly they're fighting their own
battles and at home
in private the comfort of their own home
they're their own worst enemies
the secret is to be your own biggest
critic as well as your biggest fan
the push you give yourself has to be
from a place of
love and potential not lack and despair
so i recently posted on instagram a
little cartoon of me
passing by a mirror and you see my
reflection in the mirror
and the caption says i love you and then
i challenge people to say hey what do
you what do you say to yourself when you
look in the mirror
and giving them an 18-day challenge to
say every time you see a reflection of
yourself
to say something positive whether it's i
love you or give yourself a compliment
something positive because i think most
people live in the land of negativity
all we see is all the negative things
that we're doing and all the things that
didn't work out and things that could
have been better
and that can actually be very healthy i
think you need to be your own biggest
critic i think you need to have
higher standards for yourself than what
you're currently doing but it
only works being your own biggest critic
only works when it's based off a
foundation of
love when it's based on a foundation of
i am an amazing human being and i love
myself
and i suck at all of these skills the
problem that most people have is you see
that you suck at a skill that you didn't
get the result that you're not good on
camera the first time you go out
you didn't get the result you didn't
land the sale you didn't make the deal
you didn't get the date you know
whatever it is you didn't get the result
and then you think that you suck as a
human because you don't have the skills
it's the opposite you're you're amazing
as a human
it has to be from a foundation of love
that you love yourself
and that you suck at the skills and then
you can beat yourself up over how do i
get better how do i improve how do i
acquire the skills how do i move forward
towards my goals
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
here below me or if you want to hear
what every stressed out person needs to
hear check the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe i'll see you there